luca uh shaq here you've been a pro
since you're 16. i've never been a guy
that
has the ability to take the last shot so
my question is at what point in your
career did you say
i want to be the guy that takes the last
shot was it uh in europe or was it
when you got to the nba i mean it was in
europe already
you know but that brings the trust from
the team uh i know my team trusted me
it was before nearly two but you know if
two guys go on me
somebody's open so i think find the best
shot
and that was today i think
luca i was trying to school the guys up
here on playing overseas and how
right-hand shooters and right-hand
players go
left a lot obviously the league knows
but the fans may not know
when they let you go left it is over
what does that feel like
has that always been uh your specialty
is that from overseas is that why you
like going left so much
i mean uh it don't really matter to me i
think
of my right uh i'm a better person and
on my left is a better shot
i feel more comfortable but you know it
doesn't matter
they sent me one direction one game so i
just go there
i like that luca this is d-wave man we
in the studio we marvel
about your pace the pace that you play
the game at for all the kids out there
can you talk about
the benefits of playing a game at your
own pace at your own speed
what you able to see out on the floor i
mean for me sometimes it's like playing
a chess you know
you got to take your time and see the
moves uh but you know
obviously i'm not the fastest guy out
there so maybe that's why i play
at my own pace but you know you gotta
just see what's the defense doing
and and find the better the best shot
21 years old it's the queen's gambit for
luka doncic out there just moving chess
pieces
luca we did see something before the
game you and bobon
a nice little dancing two-step uh can
you take us through the dance moves
uh uh but you saw it it's easy
i can't do it because if it's not music
you know i can't do it if there's no
music
is there a name for this dance yes
uh luca congratulations for the first
time in a month the dallas mavericks are
back to 15 and 15. you had a long break
with no action you guys look great
congratulations congratulations
thank you